mais ceux qui commencent avec des
trompettes là ne dire que c'est la fin
de la mondialisation
et puis savez le monde de l'après
deuxième guerre n'a pas vécu des jardins
de la victoire où les gens planter des
carottes dans leurs parterres sur la
plus dense et joseph c'est je pense
qu'il faut vraiment se garder de cette
espèce d'idée que on va devenir
complètement auto suffisant on va tout
prévoir qu'on veuille bien qu'on va
vraiment rester entre eux et aux quatre
murs
la juge louise arbour hier sur nos ondes
à propos de l'avenir de la
mondialisation à cette époque de
confinement et de frontières fermées
la crise actuelle nous fait prendre
conscience de notre dépendance au monde
est une sorte d'appel à la
démondialisation se fait de plus en plus
en entendre geneviève dufour et
professeur à l'université de sherbrooke
spécialiste du droit international
économique bon soir geneviève dufour
comme ça c'est un grand mot sa
démondialisation
ça veut dire quoi mais si le courant
quand même qui existe qui existaient
avant la crise de la coved sauf que ça
devient de plus en plus sur les lèvres
de tout un chacun notre premier ministre
monsieur legault en a même parlé lors de
son point de presse de la semaine passée
démondialisation ben on pense évidemment
au contraire de mondialisation ici
probablement qu'on fait davantage
référence à la mondialisation économique
donc un démondialisation konami ce qui
amènerait finalement l'idée d'une
certaine autosuffisance nationale qui
fait en sorte que chaque pays pourrait
être capable de produire sur son
territoire les biens dans sa population
a besoin
est ce que fait possible est ce que fait
réaliste c'est possible c'est illégal
la libéralisation des échanges n'est pas
une obligation les états décident par
eux mêmes de conclure des traités de
libre-échange d'appartenir à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
même une fois qu'ils font partie de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce ou
qu'ils ont compris des accords de libre
échange
ils ont toujours la possibilité de poser
des barrières au commerce international
pour demeurer au tour suffisante du
moins dans certains domaines
donc c'est possible surtout de me des
domaines dits stratégiques par exemple
santé éducation il n'y a pas un accord
de libre échange qui force les états à
libéraliser ces domaines-là énergie
sécurité forces militaires armés donc
c'est aussi nrj c'est possible pour les
états de vraiment limiter l'impact de la
libéralisation des échanges des accords
de libre échange dans ces domaines là
après si à chaque état de décider
jusqu'à quel point il veut libéraliser
les échanges dans ces domaines là donc
c'est possible c'est légal en était
aient pensé à lui c'est ça j'allais dire
alimentaire bien sans fil le
gouvernement le gaudy a parlé beaucoup
d'achat local beaucoup a dit que le
québec devrait produire davantage ses
biens essentiels jusqu'à quel point on
peut faire fort de quelques pas de la
souveraineté alimentaire
on sait que c'est quand même
l'alimentation les produits agricoles la
production agricole c'est un domaine qui
reste un peu en marge de la
libéralisation des échanges j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup de pression depuis
1995 depuis la destitution de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce pour
que les pays considèrent les produits
agricoles les produits alimentaires
comme n'importe quel autre marchandise
c'était vraiment un des points majeurs
de du courant altermondialiste et contre
la mondialisation il y en a encore moins
que les états ont certes un outil pour
rester un peu plus souverain au niveau
alimentaire
mais il ya beaucoup de failles on sait
que canada son programme de gestion de
l'offre
malheureusement programme de gestion de
leurs
dans lesquels on a mis de plus en plus
de barrières en concluant des accords de
libre échange dans les dernières années
les états unis l'europe sont des pays
qui subventionnent leurs industries
agricoles justement pour rester
souverains au niveau alimentaire
donc si possible n'est probablement que
ça va nous amener à réfléchir sur ce
modèle là et à faire en sorte qu'on soit
toujours de qu'on soit plus souffrant au
niveau alimentaire et plus s'ouvrait sur
le plan des biens essentiels la santé
oms pensent juste aux masques en cette
semaine on a toutes sortes d'accords
avec les américains accord de
libre-échange bien sûr puis pendant
quelques jours le président des états
unis bloqué là on voit de masques au
canada oui en fait c'est possible pour
tous les pays du manque de mettre des
entraves aux importations comme les
exportations
lorsque par exemple c'est nécessaire
pour protéger la vie et la santé de
leurs citoyens
donc ce que donald trump a fait et que
par ailleurs les européens
si on fait c'est tout à fait licite au
regard des règles du commerce
international
en outre que ce soit pas appliquée d'une
manière discriminatoire ou maintenant
une restriction déguisée au commerce
donc a priori ce que donald chambre
président de garder certains produits
essentiels à la santé de la sécurité de
ses citoyens c'est est licite
après on a appris qu'ils avaient accepté
que c'est que des exportations vers le
canada c'est lorsque venus ici parce que
c'est elle qui a vu dans l'application
de ces mesures il l'a fait de manière
discriminatoire
mais une fois qu'on est 10 heures il
rend pas de conséquences
sauf que ça nous amène à nous dire
peut-être que le nouvel aliment tout
comme d'oublier quelque chose peut-être
que dans le fond
on n'est pas peut-être que la
démondialisation c'est une idée mais
peut-être qu'on devrait davantage
régionaliser nos chaînes de production
en ce qui concerne le matériel essentiel
les européens en ce moment c'est pour
tout un chacun mais ce n'est pas au
niveau national c'est au niveau régional
c'est à dire au niveau de l'europe qui
sentit peut-être qu'on devrait faire la
même chose des accords de coopération
sanitaire d'urgence sanitaire pour nous
aider au niveau régional a raccourci les
chaînes d'approvisionnement pour qu'on
soit souveraine qu'on soit autour
suffisamment dans ces matières donc une
mondialisation mais un peu plus peu plus
petit dans un sens sans refermer un peu
les circle dans trente secondes
est-ce que la démondialisation c'est
nécessairement du protectionnisme oui
c'est nécessairement de protectionniste
mais moins là où j'ai un problème majeur
c'est que quand on parle de
démondialiser de prendre soin de nos
citoyens je trouve ça extraordinaire
lorsqu'on parle de régionaliser pour
raccourcir les chaînes de production
c'est merveilleux mais ce qu'on oublie
c'est que on vit tous dans le même
bateau et louisa pour le disait bien
fière et je pense que c'est important on
est une société internationale c'est une
communauté internationale et plus on va
se replier sur nous-mêmes plus c'est
finalement les pays pauvres qui vont en
subir les conséquences
on est comblé on est ensemble de tout
cela effectivement geneviève dufour
merci bonne fin de semaine
merci beaucoup à vous aussi